alrighty starting in five
four three two
uh so my name is adam amar i
work at the scilife lab national
genomics infrastructure in
sweden and we are a core facility for
doing
uh sequencing of all types and today i'm
going to talk about a project where we
are using sequencing
uh to look at crispr cat's nine effects
so first just a few words about the the
place where i work
so we are a core facility and we are
located both in the capital in stockholm
and
also in uppsala which is another city
and this is a quite
big operation so we are 75
full-time employees and we take on all
different types of projects and have
access to
i would say most available sequencing
technology
and during 2019 we processed
about 1 000 projects and 34 000
different samples
for those of you who are not familiar
with dna sequencing i just have a very
brief
and naive introduction to how this works
so basically what we do is to start from
a sample
it could be a blood sample if we're
working with human samples for example
but we're also doing other types
of organisms where we are starting from
samples from other types of
tissues or yeah it could be leaves or
whatever
we then extract dna and in this picture
i have it in form of nice
long chromosomes but what we then need
to do is to fragment this dna into small
pieces
so these pieces are more than 100 base
pairs long
and the reason for doing that is that
the sequencing particularly cannot read
entire chromosomes unfortunately
and with most technologies we're
fragmenting this into quite small pieces
of about perhaps 200 base pairs
but what i'm going to talk about today
is other technologies where we are
looking at
dna molecules that could be several
thousand base pairs and even
maybe up to 100 000 base pairs in length
once we have the dna fragments we put
this onto our
favorite dna sequencer and there are
many different
instruments for doing this type of next
generation sequencing
and finally we end up with pretty large
data set that we need to analyze
and interpret and when it comes to this
long read sequencing technology that i
will talk about today
there are different companies who is
offering this service
and we have been using biosequencing for
quite some time
so the first instrument that we
installed was back in 2013
and to the left here you can see that
it's a quite it was a quite big
piece of equipment and difficult to get
into the lab
and more recently we installed a newer
generation of the pack buyer sequencer
to the right
which is a bit smaller and also
generates a lot more data compared to
this big
instrument before so a lot has happened
in in this technology and when it comes
to the technology itself
it produces dna sequences for very long
dna fragments
and we can then start off with the dna
molecule that are
is perhaps 10 kbs in length
so this is to the top left we then
ligate
adapter sequences to both ends of this
dna fragment
then a polymerase is bound to one of
these
adapters and when we have done that we
put this molecule onto a
sequencing chip and then the sequencing
reaction starts
and to the right you can see what
happens during this sequencing reaction
so the polymerase will
start doing sequencing and it will go
around this molecule
many many times because as you can see
this is in fact a circular molecule
so we will create many copies of this
strand
and what we then can do is to look at
all these copies
of the of the dna fragment and we can
create a consensus
read of this uh molecule and this is
something that can also be called the
hi-fi
read and it has a very high accuracy so
we can get more than 99
accuracy uh of all the bases in this
long dna fragment
which is quite unique feature of the
dna sequencing so this is one
of the long read technologies we are
also using another technology
that is completely different and this
one is a nanopore based
technology from oxford nanopore
and the way this works is that we have a
long dna molecule
that is fed through a pore and when
this molecule is being sort of pulled
down through this pore
we can read we get measurements of the
currents
when that happens and in that way we can
sort of go through this trace and we can
see which bases
are being sequenced and then get
readouts of the dna molecules
and this is a quite interesting
technology because it doesn't need any
laser or anything to that
to look at the sequence of the sequences
and this makes it possible also to
create very small sequencers
using this equipment so in fact there
are portable instruments
like this min ion to the bottom left but
then there are also higher throughput
systems like the grid ion and promethane
and we have both the min ion and the
promethane system installed
in our location okay so what are we then
doing
with all these long reads that we create
and
it can be used for many different
purposes
we are taking on all types of projects
that come to us
from swedish researchers and also from
abroad and it could be
many different types of applications
both non-human or non-clinical
but then we also have a number of
applications where we're trying to use
this for more
medical purposes
and one specific project that i can
mention because
we are doing a lot of this non-human
sequencing
and one of the biggest projects uh i
guess that's happening at all now
is the earth biogenome project and we
are taking part of this
and it's an effort to sequence basically
all
living organisms on the earth
and long-reed sequencing is actually
quite a big part of this
effort but my
specific focus or sort of my research
interesting
has been to see how we can use this type
of technology
for medical use and for human sequencing
and
uh if you're interested in this topic i
was
involved in writing this review article
that was published a year ago where we
are looking at the advantages of using
the long read sequencing
instead of the normal short read
sequencing and i should mention that
short reads are still
sort of the norm when we're talking
about ngs
but there are several advantages of of
using these long reads
and one thing that i would like to
mention specifically
is that these long reads allows us to
look at
things that we perhaps couldn't see
before
so one thing is called here the concept
of dark regions
in the human genome so as you know i
mean humans
have been sequenced for quite some time
and are being analyzed with
all types of technologies but still
there are some gaps
in the human sequence if we're now using
these short reads to to look at the
human genome
and this was a study from genome biology
last year where they looked at these
regions where there are gaps
and this is one example where we have
two genes
uh in close proximity that are quite
similar to each other and if we look at
these
short reads the illumina reits at the
top you can see these gaps
where we don't have any sequence
information because it's difficult to
align or impossible to align these reads
uniquely to these regions
but if we look at this back bioreads or
the oxford nanoparades you can see that
we covered
this entire region
and so these dark regions then
are these gaps where we don't get an
alignment in the short read data but we
can get good alignment with the long
reads
okay so this was all just the
introduction to the topic that i really
want to talk about
is and it's how we can use these
technologies
uh to study effects of crispr cas9
genome editing
i don't think i need to introduce uh
cast nine
uh or the crispr cast nine system to you
because i mean it's well known that it's
a revolutionary tool
in uh in life sciences but one thing
that has been discussed
uh quite a lot is this concept about of
target effects
so it's unintended mutations that may be
introduced
when we are doing this type of genome
editing
and there are different camps here so
there are some studies that show
that there are a lot of these uh
these unwanted mutations that can occur
when we're doing crispr cast line
editing
but then there have also been a number
of studies that have shown that perhaps
these
this is not really something that we
need to worry too much about
because we are not perhaps seeing them
uh in in living cells or in crispr cas9
edited organisms and when we're looking
at these of target sites
the usual way to to study them is to do
a sequence comparison
and what we're doing then is basically
to take the guide rna sequence
and we compare it to a reference genome
to try to see
where this guide rna is binding or
predicted to bind
and this is a quick and easy way to do
this prediction
but there are also a few drawbacks here
one is that we need a
reference sequence otherwise we don't
have anything to align it to
it might also be difficult to align
these or to sort of predict
where the guide rna binds i mean is it
really the same thing that happens
in biology that happens in the computer
and also the reference that we're using
might be different compared to the cells
that we're studying there might be
genomic variation
so can we do this in some other way and
there are in fact
methods sequencing based methods to do
this
for example circle seek and yeah there
are a few other ones as well
but these methods are all limited by
first of all that you're doing
amplification
and also that you're using short reads
this slide is just showing sort of the
concept of
genetic variation and guide rna binding
so
if we are now having a guide rna uh
it might be designed to bind to this
place here so that's the on target site
if we're looking in the reference genome
but if we are now having an individual
that has some
variation compared to the reference so
it's indicated by these
red arrows maybe it's the case that this
guide rna
will no longer bind at this on target
site
uh but instead it could bind at some
other place in the genome
uh and one question we can ask ourselves
here is if we can really study this of
target's effect if the
if we don't know the exact sequence of
the
of the individual that we are looking at
so we have been trying to look into this
by using
long read sequencing and we also have a
preprint
out on this project and here i want to
mention either hoyer who is a phd
student who has been
developing these methods that we're
using here
and the methods that we are have
developed
we call them off target sequencing and
there are two different protocols
so we have developed one protocol based
on the pac-biosequencing and this is
called
smart of target sequencing or smart ots
and then we have the oxford nanopore
version
of this that is called nano ots
and basically these protocols are quite
similar so we're starting off by
looking at genomic dna that has been
fragmented
and then at some point we perform a
casino
digestion of these molecules we ligate
some adapters and then we perform
sequencing
and one important thing to note here is
that we don't do any type of pcr
during this library preparation so it's
a completely amplification-free
protocols
we applied these methods to the heck 293
cell line
and this is a human cell line an
embryonic kidney line
and what we also did with this cell line
was to sequence this
using long hi-fi reads these high
quality reads from pak bio
and we sequence this to 18 18x coverage
and in this way we can get a pretty good
idea of
how this genome actually looks and we
can study all the bases in the genome
and see
where the guide rnas bind and the exact
sequences that they bind to
okay so the experimental setup we did
here was to perform both
these protocols both the smart
sequencing and the nanopore sequencing
and we looked at three guide rnas so
they're called atx
10 mmp14 and neck one
we also developed an analysis method to
to take the raw reads that we get from
the sequencers
to get good accurate predictions of the
guide rna binding sites
and basically what we do is to align the
reads to a reference
we then identify these cas9 digestion
sites
because what happens in the data is that
the sites where the
cast 9 digests they will give rise to
these types of peaks that are very sharp
and where we all the reeds end at the
exact same position where the cast 9 has
cleaved them
and in the next step we take all these
peaks and we
we perform a pairwise alignment to
identify which guide on it
that binds to each peak and then we
perform visualization
of the output
this is one example of how it can look
so here we see
the on target site for these three guide
rnas so we have atx and 10 to the left
mmp 14 in the middle and neck one to the
right
and then we have the smart sequencing
and the nanopore sequencing data
the red line here corresponds to
kas9 cleavage site so you can see that
we can clearly detect
these sites in on target sites with both
these methods but what was interesting
is that we also find
get this type of signal also at other
sites in the genome
so these are off target sites and here
we have three
examples of target sites for atx and 10
mmp14 and neck one
that are found by both these methods and
for the
for two of these guide rnas we have a
three base pair mismatch
when we compare the guide rna sequence
to the hick to 93
and for the neck one we even have five
mismatches but still we get binding
so that's pretty interesting i think
that we can see
this type of binding even though the
guide rna is quite different compared to
the
genomic dna sequence
here we see a visualization of the
off-target sites
that were detected by both these two
methods so these are like
our high confidence of target sites
so we have many of them for atx and 10.
you can see at the top the guide rna
sequence
and then these colored boxes represents
mismatches to this to this guide rna
sequence
and then we in some cases get signals
even though we have
insertion or deletion mismatches as well
one interesting observation is that we
can also
look at allele specific cas9 cleavage
so this is one example of a site for atx
and 10
where we see that the guide rnas
preferentially bind into one allele
so at the bottom here to the left you
can see this hi-fi data so this is the
whole genome sequencing data
and here we have two different
haplotypes so we have the reference
haplotype and we have the alternative
have to type
but if we look at the data that we get
after our
cas9 enrichment then we see only this
alternative haptic type
and it turns out if we look at the
sequences that this alternative
type has only two mismatches to the
guide rna
whereas the reference hepa type has
three mismatches
uh so from this we can conclude sort of
that the genetic variation here the snip
can affect
uh guide rna binding at least sort of in
this in vitro experiment when we're
looking at skyrim is bound
to to dna
we also were interested in seeing if we
could find these guide rna binding sites
or these cast 9 cleavage sites
without making use of the existing
reference
so for this we performed an assembly of
all this hifi data
and this was done together with json
chin who's an expert in this
type of assembly work and we were then
able to get a good
assembly of the of the hick 293 cell
line
and then we could use this assembled
version of the cell line
to once again look at their data map it
to this
to this de novo assembly and see if we
can find the cleavage sites
and it turns out that more than 98 of
the cleavage sites
could be detected in this way so this
means that we can
perhaps start to use these approaches
also for uh
for organisms where we don't have an
existing reference
we also then looked into these dark
regions that i mentioned before
uh so there were was this paper from
2019 where they detected a lot of these
dark regions
that are also present in genes
and to the bottom here on this figure
you can see this red
lines so they correspond to these dark
regions in one of the genes here called
strc
so what we did was to design guide rnas
in these specific regions and you can
see also from this illumina
whole genome sequencing reads so this is
from another project where we have whole
genome sequencing data
we don't have any reads covering this
position
but in our off-target sequencing assay
we get
very nice signal here so we can clearly
detect
off target sequencing or sort of we can
see that the cas9 can cleave at this
position
and that would not be possible to do
with these approaches that are studying
short read data and this is just one
other
example of this uh and in total we had
six of these guide rnas that we designed
in
in dark genomic regions and we could
recover the cleavage sites
in all of them so maybe this is a
new way than to to look at what happens
in these
in these like difficult regions of the
genome when we're doing genome editing
okay but so far i've been talking about
uh
looking at guide rnas or
casino cleavage just in genomic dna
but of course we're interested in what
happens in living cells when we're doing
genome editing
so to try to look at this we perform
this experiment on
on human fibroblast cells where we first
took then
a bunch of fibroblast cells and we
performed this off-target sequencing
using a specific guide rna
and then we performed genome editing of
these fibroblasts
using the same guide rna and this was a
vector-based approach for doing
genome editing and in the next step
we then took this um
this edited fibroblasts and we performed
amplicon sequencing
long amplicon sequencing over all the
predicted uh on and off target sites
that were present here so we we
amplified these regions and
and tried to see if there are any
mutations occurring
in the in the edited fibroblasts and as
control for this
experiment we also performed the same
sweetnessing and the wild type
fibroblasts
this slide shows some results so this is
uh genome editing using this mmp14 guide
rna and at the top you can see
sequencing reads from this edited
fibroblasts
and this flash here at the top the red
flash here the corresponds to the
position where the cas9 cleavage occurs
and what we could see then is that we
have a lot of small insertions and
deletions
at the cas9 cleavage sites and this
makes sense because the cast iron is
cleaved there and then we have
a dna that has been repaired but what
was also interesting here is that we see
some other things going on here like
this
more than 500 base pair deletion in one
of the molecules
uh and in some other place we had a 328
pair
base pair insertion here and this
insertion is in fact identical to the
crispr
cas9 vector so we can see that the
crisper cas9 vector
jumped in at this location during the
during the genome editing which is kind
of interesting
and if we're looking at at the wild type
fibroblast at the same position
we don't see much happening so so
we see clear evidence of genome editing
here
but what then happens at the off target
sites so we perform the same experiment
and this is
one of the off-target sites that i'm
showing here and in the edited
fiberglass and in the wild type
fiberglass we don't see any signal
at all which was kind of kind of
surprising
and we also quantified this
so this slide shows here in the middle
we have the
the cas9 site and to the left we have
the mmp14 on target
so you can see that we have an over
representation of insertions and
deletions
at the castline sites but if we're
looking at this off target
we basically don't see any signal so
from this we can conclude that we don't
see any
of target genome editing in this
experiment that we performed
uh this is kind of surprising i think
and it raises some
questions at least i had expected
perhaps to see some off-target editing
but we don't see this in the fibroblast
cells so why could this happen
and there are many possible explanations
we don't know
at this point it could have something to
do with the chromatin structure perhaps
the chromatin is closed and cannot be
edited maybe it's the crispr cas9 method
we used so we use this vector-based
approach which is kind of a
gentle approach to do editing maybe some
more
rough method would have given more of
targets mutations
or could there be some kind of
protective mechanism in the living cells
that prevents this genome editing
could it be something with the dna
repair in these fibroblasts or
something completely different and
we need to perform more experiments to
figure this out and one thing is to look
at
cancer cell lines and see if they behave
behave in the same way
okay so coming back to the initial
question how
worried should we be about this of
targets
i think this project has been a sort of
like a bit of a roller coaster because
we were in in one way we're kind of
worried because we
find a lot of of targets in vitro when
we're looking at
guidon is bound to dna and we can see
that the guide rna can bind
despite having many mismatches to the to
the genome sequence
we also find these large structural
variants at the on target site which
could also be
worrying if you want to perform this
genome editing
but on the other side we did not see
evidence of target editing
when we when we looked into living cells
so we cannot really say i would say that
we need
to study this more to get a more clear
picture what's going on here
uh so the conclusions i have until now
i mean what we have done here is to
develop this off-target sequencing
method and
using this approach and this these hi-fi
long reads
we are able to generate detailed map of
cas9 cleavage sites
we also can find evidence of
allele-specific
guide rna binding and we can detect of
target sites also
even if we're not making use of the
existing reference
but i think that we still need to learn
quite a lot about
of targets in living cells
and i have only been talking about
human sequencing so far but what about
off targets in other
organisms and i don't think it should be
a big problem
uh i mean it's relatively
straightforward to do the sequencing and
assembly of a genome to get a
reference using this hifi sequencing and
then we are able to run this off-target
assay so
it should be possible to predict of
targets also in other
species and with that i would
finally like to show which people have
been involved in
this project and i would thank like to
thank all of you for
attention
okay great job that was awesome so
pretty much from here i'll just do some
quick editing on the front and back end
since there was no
interruptions in between your
presentation and then i will have it
ready for the
event in a few weeks okay great so
what's nothing i need to sort of do
again or anything
no i thought it was great you uh
communicated clearly and it was
understandable so
it was good perfect awesome
questions for me before we wrap up here
uh no i don't think so
there's nothing else you need from me
you have all the material i suppose
will you also be like uh promoting this
in some way
before the event or how's that working
yeah we will
be promoting as we do with our events
and then we'll also be sending you some
promotional material as well if you are
interested at all
to promote on your end whether it be
media or website so you can expect to
receive
some banners and such from our team most
likely lynn
and then you can promote as you like as
well okay perfect
alrighty and it looks like the only
thing that i am
missing from you are just a few learning
objectives so i can send a reminder as
we get closer to
the event um but just a few learning
objectives for those continuing
education credits for the audience
okay yeah sure perfect all right well if
anything comes up feel free to reach out
but if not
i will send you a reminder about those
learning objectives as we get closer
perfect thank you have a good day bye
yeah bye